Привіт сьогодні 30 днів повномасштабні
вини 300 днів обмеженого попиту
українського народу російському агресору
і акції Девід місісіті попливли на о
світний процес я озирнулась система
новчани про всі ми поговоримо із Сергієм
шкалатом міністром почту та наукою
України
панам міністри доброго
часу
поставили всю систему нашої комунікації
вчителі разом педагогів наставником та
е-е нашими нашими учасниками
барту зазначить ще ми починаємо в
шістдесятку та будь-які масштабні агресії
Російської Федерації
дев'ятий клас з приводу
і вся Європа в Росії
місту своєму
початкового процесу
просила ти щось лям із солодкого на
монтажу А ось сплата пратинепіт вище
Розкажіть на що-небудь подяках
зарплата мала постанова 15 тисяч
Натиснули на сьогодні ми чітко розуміємо
Щоб
бюджет два відживні болі ми завісою
візьми з нашої України не боремося рахунок
всієї України Вже видно їх українці
ті ж навчання і темному контексті сьогодні
інформація е-е вагою на в
УАЗі та поданні
таких соціальних розливних насправді
цінником
та включаються
соціальних стандартів
у нас треба дачу до виплати за в'язаними
мовчанням то далісія і перебої за
електро пусткою зевським якоря ходить
нації ви ікло і вашому міністерству
нас на сьогодні 35 тисяч заповідей
[музика]
шкірні школи
практики з Міністерством енергетики ми
сформувалася
консультативних центрів та пункті та
колишнього обумовлену сьогодні промивання
роботи вчителя вчителя для того щоб
не так не так сильно засвоїв купу тему і
все за контекстом формула йому роботу ще
я останнього процесу ми сьогодні з
нашими пристойними університетами
формуємо максимум силу програми
педагогічної практики формування так
званова Великого тесту це дуже формати
силу нудьгу волонтерських курси
бітоаспірант для засвоєння і щоб на
цю по всій території України для
шкірного наших учнів визначається в
в тому числі і бачкам пустивці сьогодні
самого светра
взаємодія з учителем кеш виходить
тривалі вимкнули електроенергії в
масштабах це та України я буду
видобулатість новчани у вас є план на
такі випадів
випадково випадково
[музика]
електроенергії
соціальних слухачів середнього процесу
не буває
годину до ви і хто йому форми
по їх школах
4.074.74%, е зони бойових дій
асинхронному форматі
пауербанки
ми на сьогодні з нашими партнерами
треба
відкритий доступ
п'ятого класу інститут модернізації з
Мінського злиті 1335 р. Лучники старших
близько 12 клас викиди білявий доступ в
асинхронному режимі і щоб потрібні якщо в
чати програми з е в незалежному вид на
енергія після фільму
на платформі сука школи онлайн ми
розмістив і вас в іноземному форматі
500 уроки та всі форми тисячі
Розміщувальну годину ми сьогодні
сформували
з наукової четвертих класів вузькі
однозначно категорії ти ж ігровому
форматі Е ви в чати пташиний предмети
форматі на найближчі в тому числі у своєму
форматі нашу
вартість
в історії України компанії
вже результати компанії
студентів вище
найбільший момент
[музика]
Хто розуміє ми сьогодні в контексті
супу моєму бичу не 600 тисяч
ефірна година закиненим думаєш по
хорор-муму і будню і я вам дякую що
проробляю нам час був Сергій шикарно
свитий